warum machen wir das was sie machen und
wie kaffee warum machen wir es kurz das
was sie machen kreise sind absolut aber
warum will sie so sehr sagt wieso können
sie die gesetze der physik scheinbar
aufheben ich habe mich jahrelang ich an
dieses thema getraut weil ich einfach
keine gute erklärung gefunden haben
niemand konnte erklären
jeweils gut erklären brummkreisel das
was sie machen machen trotzdem heute
also der versuch und spektakuläre bilder
wirklich zum science fiction übrigens
eine show mit preisen am schluss gibt es
etwas zu gewinnen herzlich willkommen
erst mal etwas ganz anderes zwei
millionen user klickt man einen neuen
rekord gebrochen wachsenden wahnsinn
das hätte ich anfang des jahres den
kanal auf tägliche videos umgestellt
habe nie geglaubt das liegt zum dass man
erreicht jetzt bin ich mal danke sagen
also es war ein riesen dankeschön an
euch ihr seid der hammer ich bin total
begeistert wer hier mitmacht diskutiert
und euch inspirieren lassen und likes
auf die video setzt wenn ich dann in den
kommentaren lesen dass ihr euch
gipfelsieg als leistungskurs in china
weil euch ging es um dazu motiviert hat
dann geht mir das rohöl oder wenn klicks
um - im unterricht angewählt werden dann
ist das einfach gern und das motiviert
mich jeden tag weiter zu machen es ist
auch eine verrückte zeit nahezu täglich
werden neue erkenntnisse veröffentlicht
forschungsarbeiten brauchen nicht mehr
jahre publiziert zu werden sondern
manchmal nur tage und es gibt themen die
sind so absolut spannend wie schwarze
löcher oder die suche nach
außerirdischem leben dass ich einfach
ständig nach den neuesten erkenntnissen
ihre und die welt daran teilhaben lassen
möchte denn viele wissenschaftliche
publikationen waffen einfach nicht die
relevanz oder können wir nicht erklären
ich will das hier tun und mache deshalb
noch ewig weiter 2008 habe ich mit glück
zum angefangen und fixum ist damit einer
der absolut ältesten deutschen youtube
kanäle die immer noch programm machen
also 2009 an dann regelmäßig angefangen
videos zu machen und weiter geht es mit
eurer unterstützung vielen dank an euch
vielen dank an christian möller der die
videos ganz toll schneidet und wieder
kroymann der das sehr lange zeit gemacht
hat und an marius soll sehr sehr lang
die skripte korrigiert und geschrieben
hat ich suche übrigen wieder einen neuen
praktikanten der die video ausleihe wer
also interesse hat einfach an bewerbung
achten punkt net schreiben ich freue
mich über zahlreiche bewerbungen habe
ich seit mitte januar die text wirklich
wieder alle selbst also los geht's mit
warum machen fidget villa darf was sie
machen
wer ein in die hand nimmt und bewegt der
märkte sofort wir haben ein seltsames
eigenleben und umso schneller sich
drehen desto welt wird dass die achse um
diesen sich drehen scheint wie von
geisterhand gesteuert werden und diese
geisterhand erlaubt ihre tags also ich
kann den finger gerade mal drehen oder
hier auf dem finger wagen fährt aber
andere youtuber können
wichtige tricks mit dem kätzchen und
sind nur wegen dieser geist möglich aber
woher kommt diese geisterhand
es ist wie immer ganz einfach trägheit
stellt euch einen stein vor den ihr
schmeißt er fliegt unbeirrbar dahin
wohin gewinn geschmissen wurde er
verfügt über einen beharrungsvermögen
eine trägheit sondern die richtung
wechseln muss kraft aufgewendet werden
ist ja logisch warum sollte er das auch
ohne kraft man hat ja energie
reingesteckt er mit der in diese
richtung fliegt nicht in der andere das
gilt übrigens für alle in bewegung
autozüge flüge oder ihr wächst ihr kennt
das wenn ein auto in die kurve geht ihr
werdet war sie in die entgegengesetzte
richtung also in die alte richtung
gedrückt weil euer körper ja weiter in
der alten richtung fahren will die
verträge
man greife ist das genauso nur dass hier
zahlreiche steine um eine achse greifen
wenn ihre richtung geändert werden muss
kraft aufgewendet werden dementsprechend
spürt man eine gegenkraft also dieses
beharrungsvermögen dass er selbst im
auto in einer kurve spürt wenn ihr die
richtung geführt die ausrichtung der
drehachse bankkreise verändert werden
sollte hat sind greifen ihrer lage im
raum absolut stabil und umso schneller
will sich drehen desto stabiler sind sie
ein schnell gedrehtes büros coop macht
deshalb absolut verrückte dinge auf den
tisch gestellt gibt es wie ein kreisel
einfach nicht um aber da wird noch nicht
das beste ich kann es auf eine spitze
stellen und es widersetzt sich der
gravitation die von der kavitation
verursachte schwerkraft kann das virus
coop einfach nicht aus seiner lage
bringen und an einem farben wird es noch
verrückter das teleskop spielt einfach
die physik auf den kopf so sein das tut
weh aber nicht wie wir jetzt wissen es
ist die unglaubliche trägheit die bei
schnellen preisbewegungen solche effekte
verursacht deshalb werden die büros coop
immer öfter in technischen geräten
eingesetzt phones können dadurch die
lage im raum erfassen kamera
stabilisierungssystem wie gimbel liegen
dadurch absolut stabil im raum oder der
tech welt fällt durch sie einfach nicht
wohl
so und jetzt die preise der sowie
preisen gibt es diese
cosmo bild experimentierkästen im wert
von rund 90 euro absolut cool damit
könnt ihr selber spielen programmieren
und konstruieren der absolute hammer und
das müsst ihr wissen um einen der
begehrten kästen gewinnen wie viele
videos habe ich hier auf klicks um seit
dem 17 januar inklusive diesem video
gemacht seitdem die videos nämlich
täglich die antwort ist aber nicht ganz
einfach also viel spaß beim fehlen
schreibt die antwort an klickst du
mail.com bei mehreren richtigen
antworten entscheidet das los wenn ihr
kein spannendes video von wiso mehr
verpassen wollt mir liegt ein abo vor
der kasten aufs auge und vergesst nicht
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
einer playlist mit allem videos seitdem
sitzen ja mal so hier viel spaß beim
anschauen
ansonsten bis dann bleibt auf jeden fall
dran